Today I want to talk to you
about Chromosome Two.
And to do that, I've
come to Dublin Zoo.
So you can probably see some
chimpanzees here behind me.
And one of the most surprising
discoveries in modern genetics
was that these animals, which
really do look quite different
from us physically, are, at
the genetic level, almost
indistinguishable.
About 98% the same.
However, there are some
distinguishing
characteristics.
And one of these is that whereas
we have 23 pairs of
chromosomes, chimpanzees
have 24.
So we're going to look at what
happened with that extra
chromosome.
OK, so here we have some human
chromosomes and some
chimpanzee chromosomes.
And we can do a quite simple
analysis of this, which is we
can just line them up against
the matching DNA.
So when we do this, what we
find is that one human
chromosome lines up exactly
with one chimpanzee
chromosome.
And this works throughout the
whole genome, that is except
for Chromosome Two.
Because when we look at human
Chromosome Two, it lines up
with two chimpanzee
chromosomes.
And this is the same for
gorilla and orangutan.
One human Chromosome Two lines
up with two chromosomes in the
other species.
So what we know is that these
two chromosomes fused to
create human Chromosome Two.
This then created a genetic
incompatibility between the
two lineages, a permanent
separation,
a point of no return.
So actually, this is a really
significant event in the story
of our genome.